give some right proper alias that bra
attack the block has a very simple
premise essentially some aliens invade a
little area of Britain and some Punk UK
kids decide to beat him up
that's basically it however the director
Joe Cornish strains a lot out of such a
small plot
it's just aliens and there's kids and
let's kill him the director does such a
good job making it a really quick fast
pace and fun film and he's able to do a
lot of really good scenes out of it all
the kids have really excellent chemistry
with one another they really seem like
they're just a group of neighborhood
Punk's that they've been doing it for a
long time and they're friends and they
made me grow up together you really get
a good sense of community there I like
the lead kid Moses he had a lot of
strength him and he really did seem like
a leader of these kid I can kind of see
this becoming a little more of an adult
style of Goonies where you know there's
just these group of kids and there's
this big adventure and what we're gonna
do but don't get me wrong this is not a
movie you want to take your ten-year-old
to because it's a lot more intense than
the Goonies but nuts he discovered a
species he were too unknown to science
Tilly maybe there was a party at the zoo
and a monkey shagged a fish the film has
a big flaw for me though that really
made it hard for me to appreciate the
film as much as I would have liked to
the film opens immediately with this
group of kids robbing this innocent girl
and although later in the film their
relationship matured and develop more
and the kids became more likable the
first half of the movie had a really
hard time liking the kids because they
were essentially just punk kids - the
kind of kids that I see like in a movie
theater talking or being annoying or out
on the street and oh my god punk kids
car they're the kind of kids that when
you're driving down the street they will
walk out right in front of you you know
what I mean any I just don't like those
kind of kids and so for the first half
of this movie I had a hard time enjoying
them later on it got better because I
was able to see them develop more and I
was able to get a little bit more
attached to their characters and they
became more mature throughout this
intense situation that they were in but
for the first half of the movie I think
that's a big flaw that showed them to be
like these punk kids and for me kind of
got on my nerves a little bit yo check
it more more walk them tinks ah lovely
fireworks mommies and invasion
I'm kidding them I'm killing them
straight let's get to not block
according to box office mojo the film's
budget is 13 million dollars as
extremely low for a sci-fi film with
aliens and invasion and all that stuff
and the movie really used that budget
very well even though you could really
tell the aliens or more than likely guys
in suits or some sort of practical
effect I usually like practical effects
a lot more than CGI effects and so they
were fun you know it was a fun
old-fashioned type sci-fi movie what is
that I'm pissing myself in it by the
same time this is sick it's just a good
fun old fashioned type movie I had a lot
of enjoyment out of it however the fact
that the kids were portraying as these
punks
you know is gang it was a little harder
for me to get attached to them at first
the film also has an excellent
soundtrack I really like the soundtrack
of this movie it reminded me a lot of
the soundtrack for Hannah or Scott
Pilgrim really good job of the
soundtrack
hey she's safe no I didn't like love the
movie or anything but I had a lot of fun
watching it so I'm going to give a tag
my block of B+ I would give it a lower
grade like a B if it was a much higher
budget film but since they were able to
get so much out of such a tiny budget
I'm gonna up into a B+ because I really
admire that because that's what I do man
that's why I make a short movie it's
like I got nothing so I try to get as
much out of it as possible and I really
admire that so if you like this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck man eyes